you're married you have a great family
what advice would you give uh to me and
to others like me
who are dumb [ __ ] and and i have not
found david well you're a great guy so
this definitely doesn't necessarily
apply to you but be someone who someone
would want to be in a relationship with
there's a lot of people out there that
want a great partner they want someone
in a relationship but
why would someone want to be in a
relationship with you you know maybe you
bicker a lot maybe you're jealous maybe
you uh maybe you lie
maybe you
you know
maybe you're cruel
maybe you're
you don't have a sense of humor maybe
you're you know you're not kind like
what is
what is it about you
that people would not enjoy being around
or that people avoid fix that well this
this applies to me as well like you you
said something with campaigns one of the
things you admire is the the discipline
it takes to sort of juggle so many
things
successfully i'm not sure i'm very good
at that
so juggling all this hard work and then
also a relationship also relationship
also family all these kinds of
priorities i mean that requires
having your [ __ ] together it does it's a
different thing but it's also you got to
find the right person there's a lot of
people who sell for they settle for sexy
they settle for hot for all right okay
settle for the wrong person like you can
get hot and nice
they're out there yeah but don't get hot
and mean
hot means not fun then you get amber
hurt yeah you know and then you end up
driving yeah yeah yeah you can be
deceived by perfect symmetry so you
don't think it's a good idea to record
your partner i think you should afford
all conversations
the cia's doing it no matter what i
assume that every conversation i have is
recorded because i'm pretty sure it is
even when we had dinner with alex jones
he was recording yeah i still remember
that
i didn't know that i was recording huh
he might you know what it'd be funny if
he is this yeah he could be
could be
my advice about relationships is be
somebody
and then also like
find someone who you can grow with
right you don't want to be with someone
who doesn't share your uh your value
someone you don't want to be with
someone who makes excuses you don't want
to be with someone who's lazy or who's
spiteful you want to be with someone
who's like genuinely kind that's one of
the things that i really love about my
wife and she's very smart and she works
hard she's like she's a dedicated
disciplined person but she's also really
nice that's why one of the things i like
the most about her she's so nice she's
always smiling
and that energy is great yeah i mean
you've seen us together yeah you've hung
around with us she's fun
yeah she's a lot of fun yeah she makes
you just feel great to be alive it's
good to have people like that aren't you
she's happy she's a happy person she's
happy to be around that's the kind of
people that you could have in your life
as friends
and as co-workers and as lovers and
wives and husbands you can find those
people they're real and when you find
those people your life is better like to
have a good tribe
is very important to have a good tribe
of people you know and i think if
there's anything that i'm very very
fortunate about it's the the people that
i'm around i have very good friends and
one of which is you
it's so valuable to have quality people
around you because it makes you want to
do better because you admire the hard
work that these put people put in like
my campaigns or goggins or many of my
friends and people that are generous and
people that are curious and people that
are honest
they inspire you to do the same and it's
extremely valuable it's one of the most
most valuable things
is to surround yourself with positive
healthy
friendly generous people that's why i
cut out them dylan for my life i broke
up with him he's getting married no it's
over it's none of those things the taxes
non-stop the nonstop conspiracy theories
the non-stop mocking of of my eastern
european origins
it's just not healthy for me
um plus he's physically abusive and
towering figure with both emotions boy
physically
no no i love him okay he worked out he
would be a house
he's got a large frame you know
you